افاد مراسل الجزيره باستشهاد شاب فلسطيني
برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بلده
اليامون غرب الجنين بالضفه الغربيه وقد
دارت اشتباكات بين مقاومين وقوات الاحتلال
خلال اقتحامها البلده كما اعتدت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على احد المسعفين
الفلسطينيين بالضرب خلال اقتحامها مدينه
جنين قبل اعتقاله وكان المسعف الفلسطيني
يسير في الحي الشرقي من المدينه بشكل
اعتيادي ودون ان يشكل اي خطر على قوات
الاحتلال وبثت منصات فلسطينيه مشاهد تظهر
عمليات تجريف وتخريب قامت بها جرافات
عسكريه اسرائيليه للبنى التحتيه في شوارع
الجنين بالضفه الغربيه عقب اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال للمدينه كما تظهر الصور انتشار
تعزيزات عسكريه لاليات الاحتلال في احياء
عده من مدينه ومخيم
جنين وفي نابلس فهمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيمي عسكر الجديد وبلاطه خلال
اقتحامها مدينه نابلس شمال الضفه الغربيه
وسمع دوي اطلاق نار في مخيم بلاطه كما
ازالت جرافه عسكريه العوائق ودمرت منشات
وجرفت بعض الشوارع في
المخيم كما اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي شابين فلسطينيين في مخيم عيده
شمال مدينه بيت لحم جنوب الضفه الغربيه
خلال اقتحامها للمخيم وانتشرت قوات راجله
من جيش الاحتلال في ازقه المخيم كما داهمت
عددا من المنازل قبل ان تنسحب من
المخيم واقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مدينه دوه جنوب الخليل من مدخلها الشرقي
واعتقلت شابين وتمركزت وسط المدينه وكانت
اخر احصائيه لنادي الاسير الفلسطيني قد
اشارت الى ان قوات الاحتلال اعتقل اكثر من
6330 فلسطينيا في الضفه الغربيه منذ بدايه
الحرب على غزه في السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي